what kind of microphone do i use so i
got a great question front of my youtube
viewer is sameer love you guys who wrote
in to say thanks Evan really for what
you're doing is a great job please any
info about a microphone what type of
microphone to use and how do you use it
thank you in advance so i use two
microphones my main microphone for these
videos is just a little sony clip mike
i'll come a little closer to you guys
can see so it's just little standard
issue you go to the sony store they have
this clip my guy it's under 100 bucks
and just clips to the top of your shirt
the wire runs through your shirt so i
run it underneath my shirt and then
there's a little thing that I keep in my
pocket here and this is pretty basic
right it just says power on power off
it's on right now if I turn it off and
then turn it back on a little light
flashes and that's it it's a it's a one
direction so you got to make sure that
it is pointing up towards you and that's
how I do most of these videos so it's
not crazy super expensive gear when I'm
doing my radio show or from doing a set
recording piece that's not in front of
the camera I use a Yeti microphone so
this is my Yeti and I'm not using this
you don't see this in my videos here but
again if I'm doing any kind of recording
this is what i'm going to use i bought
this up with the mac store it's great
quality and i like the look of it to
kind of reminds me of david letterman
i'm hosting some kind of late night show
or something there's a lot of different
options on here they can see on the back
is that zooms in these four settings
here are basically just if you're going
to talk straight into it or you can do
an interview where you can have two
sides to it or you can have it be get
everything in the room and I don't know
what the for setting is I really just
used the one direction because I'm just
that's just me in front of the camera so
that's what I use standard issue so
anyclip mic for most of videos yeti
microphone from the mac store for
or everything and I'm recording just on
the computer that's it believe those are
watching like the video you can support
me by clicking on the link in the
description and leave a comment let me
know what you think look at my face
subscribe to the channel thank you so
much I'll see you soon